you are watching a video right now this
is a video you're probably watching on
your TV at home on your computer at the
office or on your phone while sitting on
the toilet while you watch every second
there are millions of pixels lighting up
your screen with High defition images
with Rich stereo sound both coded with
billions of bits streaming to you
through the internet mobile devices
Smart TVs and easy access to high-speed
internet have made this all seem common
trivial even but the magic of how the
images and sounds are coming to you
instantly just about anywhere is a
pretty incredible feat of engineering
the technology has become so commonplace
that the appearance of a buffering
symbol even on mobile internet is
considered a failure of the streaming
service a problem we had to contend with
while building our own streaming service
nebula and as W over Productions did
before me in telling the story of why
nebula exists I'm telling the story of
how it exists
because it's something I help build I'm
speaking directly to camera for the
first time when we started out nebula
didn't have any dedicated staff of
Engineers it was an experimental side
project so we built the first version on
syy which offers white label streaming
video services using their tools we had
a full worldwide service up and running
in just a few months the problem was
that syy wasn't built to handle the
complexities of running hundreds of
channels or releasing hundreds of videos
per month or streaming to hundreds of
thousands of active subscribers as
nebula outgrew them we knew we needed to
build something fully custom from the
ground up a streaming system we named
Sterilite from the software that
compresses and delivers the video to
servers around the world to the apps and
browsers you watch them on and the
internet in between this technology has
advanced drastically in the last decade
this is how it
works if you were born after the year
2000 streaming video might not seem like
a big deal but in the early internet
days of the 1990s streaming a video was
basically Unthinkable in 1999 the
trailer for Star Wars Episode 1 The
Phantom Menace broke records by being
downloaded over 1 million times in 24
hours downloaded not streamed because
streaming a movie trailer at any level
of quality simply wasn't possible for
the dialup modem connection speeds
common at the time
in those days most people connected to
the internet using their telephone lines
incredibly slow internet that was
measured in the kilobits per second not
the mega and gigabits we are accustomed
to today those modems worked through
modulation of a digital signal onto an
analog sound signal being transferred
over the copper telephone wires if the
amplitude of the sound was high it was a
binary one if the amplitude was low it
was a zero the transmitting computer
would modulate the data into sound waves
and the receiving computer would
demodulate modulate demodulate modem to
an extent this is how most physical
cables work short of fiber optics but
doing this over copper telephone wires
is prone to loss so the fastest speed
you could possibly hope to get in the
best conditions was 56 kilobits per
second for comparison even a 720p
YouTube video has a bit rate of 5
megabits per second around 90 times
faster than a dialup modem could receive
by 2005 Broadband connections like cable
modems were much more common providing
the infrastructure for three guys in
Northern California to start a video
dating service called YouTube that year
when Justin Timberlake and Janet Jackson
had their Infamous wardrobe malfunction
at the Super Bowl halftime show the trio
realized that they couldn't find any
video of the incident online and
repurposed YouTube to be a digital video
repository that anyone could use nearly
two decades later home internet speeds
have advanced significantly but more
crucially mobile internet connections
have gotten so fast that they often
rival dedicated home connections the
smartphone revolution has driven
cellular data speeds to insane new
levels adding more and more frequencies
and ways to squeeze more data onto them
we now have the Technologies to send
that data over long distances quickly
but that's just part one of the problem
when you clicked on this video you
expected it to play immediately without
buffering that can happen if the video
is stored on a server near you and you
are one of the privileged people to have
access to fast internet but that isn't
always the case and solving those edge
cases is where the smaller Indie
streamers like nebula need to play smart
the primary constraint is bandwidth
while high-speed connections are common
in the western world not all users will
have fast internet access and even if
they do problems can still occur which
may lead to degraded performance
a poorly shielded microwave can
interfere with Wi-Fi internet service
providers may have temporary slowdowns
during times of peak usage and going
through a Subway tunnel on your morning
commute may cause you to intermittently
lose signal to help combat these
inconsistencies the server will encode
the video several times with different
bit rates bit rate simply means the
speed at which the video will need to be
transmitted in order to avoid buffering
or pauses once the transcoder limits the
bit rate it will ALS also need to lower
the resolution of the video to keep the
overall visual quality of the video
watchable low bit rates combined with
high resolution result in blocky video
that is very distracting the transcoder
creates files with different bit rates
and resolution pairings producing lower
quality smaller files all the way
through larger 4K files when a video
player is streaming a video it isn't
downloading the entire file at once it
downloads chunks at a time this allows
for changes in streaming quality during
playback if your internet connection
slows down the service can switch to the
lower resolution version of the file on
the Fly the video may not look as good
but it will keep playing and hopefully
switch back later when the connection
improves it also allows for starting
playback in the middle of the video if
you want to pick up a video where you
left off yesterday there's no need to
download the entire file plus since most
videos don't get watched to 100%
completion this approach also saves
countless dollars on bandwidth bills for
nebula sterlite system the team uses
fragmented MP4s for this packaging this
lets us separate the audio files from
the video audio requires much smaller
file sizes compared to video and Studies
have shown that poor audio quality will
impact the viewers experience more than
poor video quality in other words a bad
sounding video will look worse by
separating audio and video the team
ensures the audio quality Remains the
Same between all resolutions once the
files air split text manifests are
written to describe the precise timing
and file location for every chunk of
video These manifests are what the video
player reads when they load a video Once
the central servers have finished
processing the new files it needs to
store them across multiple different
servers to ensure there is a copy near
the viewer there is a popular
misconception that storage and bandwidth
are the expensive parts of running a
streaming service while file storage was
once very expensive modern services like
Amazon web services S3 and backblaze B2
provide pretty inexpensive storage
around 3.7 million new videos are
uploaded to YouTube every day so we
imagine their storage cost is higher
than ours but they also own all of their
data centers we think it's safe to say
that YouTube probably pays less per
video for storage than nebula does but
for context nebula's entire catalog is
currently around 30 tabt we pay less
than $200 per month to stores that's
less than I pay for my production team's
Adobe subscriptions with the files
transcoded packaged and stored the next
step is to deliver them to viewers when
a user requests to watch a video the
service could serve it to them directly
from Storage but depending on where in
the world the viewer lives that might be
a slower process this is why we need a
CDN CDN stands for content delivery
Network this is a network of servers all
over the world spaced out specifically
to ensure that there's a server near any
given video viewer when you tap to watch
a video the service matches you to the
CDN server closest to you and starts the
stream the previous steps were all just
preparation to ensure that this local
server had what it needed cdns have the
capacity to transfer the 2,000 terabyt
of video data that nebula delivers every
month the CDN nebula uses fastly uses a
two-step caching system utilizing three
sets of servers first there's the local
servers called nodes these are ideally
located very close to you when your app
or browser requests a video the service
first checks for the files at your local
node if it doesn't find them it checks
the caching servers the caching servers
act as a second layer of temporary
storage they contain all of nebula's
catalog videos allowing them to serve
nodes in their region quickly finally
there's the origin the data center with
the servers and hard drives containing
all of the original transcoded videos
duplicating every video file on every
node around the world would take up a
lot of space and use a lot of bandwidth
so the system prioritizes newer high
demand videos If a video is especially
popular there's a good chance that
someone in your geographical region has
beaten you to watching it first if the
video is older and less popular the
chances that it has that initial
buffering time is higher it's a lot like
how a retail supply chain Works items
are produced at the factory the origin
shipped to a warehouse the caching
servers and then distribute it to local
stores the nodes for quick convenient
access If you experience stuttering or
lag or general poor video performance
this is often the root cause the video
files are being served to the CDN nodes
on demand if you're using a service with
millions or billions of users you'll
likely never be the first person to want
to watch a particular video for a
smaller service like nebula if you live
in an area where there aren't many
subscribers you're more likely to end up
waiting for that first transfer more
often as nebula grows this becomes
counterintuitively less of a problem
nebula is growing incredibly quickly and
we've more than doubled our direct
subscribers in
2023 I mentioned earlier that there's a
misconception about storage and
bandwidth being the expensive parts we
could only guess what someone like
YouTube pays for bandwidth and Delivery
for their videos but for comparison as
of September 2023 nebula currently has
around 300,000 active monthly users and
spends less than $20,000 per month on
bandwidth to serve them all the biggest
hard cost for a streaming service is
hiring talented Engineers building this
complex system requires front-end and
back-end web Engineers to create the API
and build a website development
operations people to make sure the
systems are all healthy and running
correctly quality assurance people to
help find bugs in the code before it
ships and countless product designers
and app developers to bring the
experience to all of the devices you
want to watch the videos on to get a
video playing on your screen you need an
app app with a video player sometimes
this happens in a web browser and
sometimes it happens in a dedicated app
for most internet enable systems there's
a client and a server the client is the
program making the requests and the
server is the system that answers those
requests most modern software is written
so the majority of the logic and
processing happens on the server side
not the client this helps to simplify
Development Across devices if there are
going to be any major show stopping
software bugs it's better to have them
happen on the server where the engineers
and development operations teams can
quickly roll out fixes without needing
to go through an app approval process or
release new updates for a video service
the server sends a list of videos and
all of the thumbnails to go with it and
The Client app renders those into some
kind of human readable list for you to
browse through there are different kinds
of apps web apps mobile apps desktop
apps TV apps different different devices
will often require that apps be written
in completely separate programming
languages like Swift for iOS cotland for
Android or JavaScript and typescript for
smart TVs and even incredibly Niche
languages like bright script for Roku
which makes hiring even more difficult
to confuse matters further many of these
devices will require that apps be
distributed through proprietary app
stores with their own approval processes
when nebula launched on LG smart TV app
earlier this year it took months to get
approved on the store and quick update
while we were working on this video LG
told us that nebula's lgbtq content was
a violation of their content policy and
the app needed to be removed in 46
countries we asked for Clarity on this
policy but we were only told that it was
for religious and cultural elements in
those countries we're not really sure
why they didn't just remove it
themselves they haven't responded to our
requests for further discussion
regardless of the outcome having these
conversations and jumping through these
hoops consumes a lot of resources and is
generally just a pain in the ass this is
just one of the many apps we had to
develop getting approval for iPhone
updates however typically happens in a
matter of hours catering to each user's
watching habits was an expensive startup
cost in development while nebula has
only recently started tracking watch
Time by device nearly half of all
YouTube views happen on TV screens if
any streaming service wants to hold your
attention it needs to be available no
matter how you want to watch and that
means supporting a wide variety of
options native mobile apps enable you to
download videos to watch offline in case
you're on a long flight without Wi-Fi TV
apps make for comfortable watching in
your living room web apps mean access
from any device with a web browser which
can have some surprising results nebula
even has a small number of viewers who
watch from their web browser in their
Teslas it can be tricky to account for
all of these variables in this equation
different devices running different
operating systems running apps written
in different languages with different
screen sizes and design requirements
communicating over connections that
could range from high-speed fiber optics
to a spotty cellular signal in an
airport bathroom when you open your
phone to watch a video
what you're really launching is a
massively complex system that depends on
a team of incredibly skilled software
engineers and designers who not only
make all of this possible across all
these scenarios but make it look easy
nebula is built as a partnership between
the platform and the creators the
company provides the business structure
design and Engineering that make up the
platform and the creators bring their
videos and creat a vision the platform
will never be complete
that's the nature of software but this
partnership has already led to a stable
ecosystem nebula has hundreds of
thousands of subscribers and the number
two subscriber retention stats of any
streaming service second only to Netflix
this retention is possible because our
audience really cares about our creators
and believes in what we're building we
respond by making increasingly better
videos for them to watch which gives
them a reason to stay if virtuous cycle
it's a very different kind of audience
relationship and we want to safeguard
that relationship and ensure nebula
stays true to the people who supported
it from day one that's difficult to do
when you take investment from Venture
Capital firms we don't want to do that
and that limits Us in some ways for a
subscription business the key is to find
a balance between cash and revenue cash
is money you have today revenue is money
that comes in over time if we were were
a VC funded startup we'd have a bunch of
cash and we'd spend it on things we hope
would bring in money later like funding
originals but we aren't VC backed we are
fan supported so instead of sacrificing
the platform's autonomy to shadowy
figures in Silicon Valley we turned to
our most loyal subscribers the truth is
we have
680,000 customers we can see from our
retention stats that many of them have
no intention to cancel their
subscription so why not offer them a way
to purchase a lifetime subscription if
every single one of those subscribers
purchased a lifetime subscription for
say
$300 we would have $24 million in the
bank to fund the projects they signed up
to watch so that's what we did and it
has allowed us to raise Capital without
turning to venture capital firms you can
buy a lifetime subscription right now
that program has been incredibly
successful for us it turns out a lot of
people don't like having reoccurring
subscriptions every month and would
prefer to just pay once Upfront for
Lifetime access and we've used that
funding to Greenlight a lot of really
exciting projects including some from
our team that we can't yet announce
that's unheard of for a streaming
platform it's blurring the lines between
Hollywood and creator-owned businesses
we've even greenet entire movies that
our creators have written like Patrick
Willams and Abigail Thoren that's
ultimately our goal to give creators
opportunities that they traditionally
can't get because some guy in La won't
even let them in the room this is where
the line between educational video and
AD becomes blurry so I'm going to
demarcate it this channel depends on
funding nebula provides us if you've
been subscribed to this channel for more
than 3 years you've seen the huge
increases in production quality that
nebula has facilitated we first started
using 3D animations in the logistics of
D-Day nebula original series those were
all done within After Effects which is
extremely Limited in 3D animation then
we upgraded to blender and Cinema 4D
thanks to increased Revenue driven by
nebula sponsorships now I think it's
fair to say that we are a world-class
engineering Animation studio just look
at our recent space shuttle series for
proof of that we are committed to
continuing that Trend investing more and
more into our production quality because
I won't be happy until we are the best
engineering Film Studio on the internet
so please consider signing up for nebula
or even better switching to a lifetime
membership of course the regular monthly
and yearly options are still available
too you can sign up to a monthly yearly
or lifetime membership with the link in
the description or sign up by pressing
the button on screen right
now